[Music]
the new wreckit-ralph ii trailer is the
ultimate summary of what goes on on the
internet we got totally rickrolled but
did you notice that this trailer also
features some brand new characters check
them out don't forget to hit that
notification valve to never miss another
video and be sure to check out our
community section for even more fun
now let's check out what the deal is
with the new trailer oh no I'm freaking
out hard aunt Cass let's start with one
of the most unexpected cameos in this
trailer by now we totally notice that
wreck-it Ralph too will be full of jokes
adults will appreciate as well when
Ralph and vanellope enter the internets
they get immediately bombarded with
various advertisements but did you
notice what was actually on these ads
the sassy housewives who want to meet
you featured the one and only aunt Cass
from big hero 6 it's totally the same
picture we're not really sure what
record Ralph 2 is trying to tell us but
it's safe to say this movie is full of
subtle adult humor the new trailer also
introduced a brand new character his
name is double Dan because well there's
a second head growing from his shoulder
sure he's a little bit weird and there's
probably a reason why you can only find
him on the dark side of the internet but
we also love that the movies introducing
some new characters and not just reusing
the old ones hopefully this means we'll
also get to see doubled and in another
Disney movie we all know how much Disney
loves doing crossovers and while Dan
might look totally scary we'd bet he'll
definitely make us giggle grumpy the
dwarf okay so we know Disney Princesses
will be making an appearance and we'll
talk more about that in just a bit but
did you notice grumpy the door you can
find him on the official record Roth 2
poster that was released with the brand
new trailer what's even more surprising
is that grumpy can't be found anywhere
near Snow White he's actually hanging
out next to Belle of course he's still
being as grumpy as Eve who knows maybe
we'll also see Snow White's dwarves
interact with other princesses how cool
would that be
question is is grumpy alone or does he
have anyone else with him - sure
do like this new tail er now here's a
name we haven't heard in a while
although iconic Winnie the Pooh isn't
mentioned that much these days
Disney decided to pay tribute to one of
the most underrated Winnie the Pooh
characters and we're totally here for it
er is an absolute sweetheart but what we
love even more is the fact that this is
an actual crossover between Winnie the
Pooh and Disney Princesses anyone needs
new fanfiction material teen Disney
Princesses and Winnie the Pooh
characters interacts would be the
ultimate dream tribute to pop vinyl
figurines you probably noticed the
strange square-headed humans walking
around throughout the trailer we believe
that this is actually Disney's tribute
to pop vinyl figurines
they're basically miniature figures of
your favorite characters seriously you
can pretty much find any character you
love they have become quite the
collectibles and nowadays people can own
an impressive amount of these toys it's
been reported that the toys are as
popular as ever with sales increasing by
almost 30%
it's no wonder Disney decided to pay
them a tribute especially since you can
now also get wreck-it Ralph to figurines
BRB or during every single one of these
after this video
Super Mario ok we're putting this one
under a question mark because we just
couldn't tell whether this is just a
mere coincidence or not it looks like
Super Mario or at least parts of Super
Mario made it in the movie we all know
how popular this game is so this is
totally not surprising you can totally
see the Super Mario question mark box
and one of the backgrounds of the
trailer but if you look closely at one
of the new posters for the movie you can
also see another Super Mario hint can
you spot the mushroom we're pretty sure
this is not a coincidence
maybe Disney is hinting at a potential
Super Mario Brothers movie we'll have to
wait and see Star Command come in Buzz
Lightyear and baymax Toy Story
characters will definitely be around in
this movie although we couldn't see
Woody Buzz like you're definitely made
an appearance and right beside him is
vay max how cool is that we love seeing
these type of characters interact with
each other our just knowing about each
other's existence
seriously these two just looked like
they would be total BFFs
they'll probably only have a small cameo
in the actual movie but we'll take it
Disney also change to BuzzFeed's name
into buzz a holic we want to imagine
that they actually mean Buzz Lightyear
because we definitely agree do people
assume all your problems got solved
because a big strong man showed up more
princess interaction and the last but
not least it's one of our favorite
subjects ever Disney Princesses it's
really no secret we're obsessed with
them but ever since wreck-it Ralph two
trailers came out we just can't get over
them seeing all Disney Princesses
interact with each other is an
unforgettable moment we see them pose
for the camera love Penelope's just
goofing around but just look at how they
look at her it's like she's their little
sister just imagine having Disney
Princesses as your sisters it would
honestly make our lives 100% more
exciting just look at them pulling faces
people have already started making jokes
that Disney's should do this movie
without Ralph and just have Disney
Princesses take back the Internet and
while we do love wreck-it Ralph
we kind of agree we just wish the entire
focus would be on the princesses they
totally deserve to have their special
movie what do you think are you worried
that Disney overhyped the movie or will
we actually get enough memorable and
mind-blowing moments don't forget to let
us know if you spot any other
interesting characters in the trailer
and that's it for our video thanks for
watching see you next time
[Music]